الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان وزير الدفاع السرجير
شوكو او عزا بتعزيز العنصر القتالي لدى
القوات البحريه والجويه والصاروخيه
الاستراتيجيه وذلك بعد اجتماع الناقشه
زياره عدد القوات المسلحه الروسيه اضافت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مع قيادات الجيش بشان زياده عدد القوات
المسلحه الروسيه الى مليون ونصف مليون
جندي بحلول عام 2026
واقل الكلام من زياده عدد القوات الروسيه
ياتي بسبب الحرب التي يشنها الغرب
بالوكاله ضد موسكو وكان وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيسون تفقد مقر تجمع القوات
الروسيه المعروف باسم قوات الشرق في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
لوزير شويكو استمع الى القيادات العسكريه
بشان الوضع الحالي والتقدم في تنفيذ
المهام القتاليه الرئيسيه
اهتماما خاصا لتنظيم الدعم الشامل للقوات
المشاركه في العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وكذلك عمل الوحدات الطبيه والخلفيه
تنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
الدريدي رانيا اذا هنالك رفع الجاهزيه
القوات الروسيه بالعتاد والعناصر ايضا هل
اوضحت وزاره الدفاع الاسباب التي تدعو
لذلك
[تصفيق]
لا يدور عن الجاهزي القتاليه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه بل عن خطط استراتيجيه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه للفتره ما بين عام
و2020 هناك تغييرات على نطاق واسع ستجري
في همم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وذلك بامر من
الرئيس الروسي
الحديث عن ثلاث نقاط اساسيه النقطه الاولى
فداء وهي زياده عدد قوات القوات المسلحه
الروسيه لتصل الى مليون و500,000 عسكري
روسي بعد ما كانت العام الماضي 150 اي
الحديث يدور عن زياده عدد قوات الروسيه
بمقدار 350 الف عسكري روسي فضلا عن ذلك
النقطه الثانيه يدور عن تعزيز العنصر
القتالي للقوات البحريه والجويه
والصاروخيه الاستراتيجيه والنقطه التاليه
وهي اجراء تغييرات همم اداريه عسكريه همم
في روسيا هو هنا السبب يدور بالدرجه
الاولى على الاقل بحزم ما اعلن عنه الكريم
قبل قليل بسبب الحرب بالوكاله التي يخوضها
الغرب على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ضد روسيا
همم هنا الحديث يدور عن ايضا عن اجراء على
سبيل المثال همم
تشكيل مجموعه عسكريه مكتفيه ذاتيا في
المناطق الاربعه التي تم ضمها الى الاراضي
الروسيه وايضا عن تشكيل اتحاد عسكري له
همم
موسكو ولينينغراد وذلك على ما يبدو يمكن
انه قد يكون مرتبط ايضا فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه انضمام وحديث وعزم فنلندا
والسويد انضمام الى الحل في شمال الاطلسي
اذا هناك تجديد التغييرات جذريه سيتمها
على نطاق واسعه سيتم اجراءه خلال الاعوام
الثلاثه المقبله وذلك مرتبط بالدرجه
الاولى بالاوضاع السياسيه والعسكريه
والسياسيه وما تعتبرهم واسكت تهديد لامنها
القومي العاسيه ما في ما يتعلق باقتراب
بنيه التحتيه لحلف الناس من حدودها
واراضيها وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتوسع اللي
يحب شمال الاطلسي من الناحيه الشماليه
فينلاندا واسود وايضا فيما يتعلق باتساع
مساحه الاراضي الروسيه بعد ضم المناطق
الاربع الاخرانيه اراضيها كل هذه
التغييرات همم التغييرات والاوضاع
السياسيه على ما يبدو فدا دفعت موسكو
اتخاذ هذه الاجراءات لتعزيز امنها القومي
معنا من موسكو